hey everybody welcome to the great big
story youtube channel i'm jillian i'm
dave
welcome to the show
here at great big story we love animals
and first we're gonna head underwater
and meet a guy who swims with sea lions
i kind of compare it with being at a
giant
dog park some of them love it like you
start giving them armpit scratches and
they're just like giant dogs they just
start rolling around and they're flying
all around you but these animals are
huge
people are intimidated by them but once
you once you learn their behavior
they're just right into you right away
they just look at you like a big chew
toy
[Music]
i could never see myself living anywhere
other than the pacific northwest
i could literally spend every single day
the rest of my life and never travel
anywhere other than vancouver island and
i would still never have enough time to
see this whole place
my first introduction to the ocean would
have definitely come from my mom just
made the sea lion right there later on
in life realize it is a pretty unique
experience to get to out and spend time
with these animals on a regular basis
sea lions are a large
intelligent animal and they're very
sensitive of what your intentions are
and and how they choose to interact with
you is totally their choice
if you're comfortable and and they're
inquisitive they'll come and they'll
chew on your fins or they come up and
they chew on the edge of your mask or
give you big kisses on the lips or big
hugs they wrap their fins around you and
give you a big hug
[Music]
people get sketched out about it
like i've had lots of people contact me
and be like don't you think those things
are aggressive just because in animals
putting its mouth on you doesn't mean
it's doing it in a harmful way
they don't have hands they can't explore
their world with anything other than
their mouth
there's people that spend
a lot of money to travel to the other
side of the planet to watch a group of
large migratory animals in africa or
something say and here i can just go out
on my boat and it's not something i take
for granted at all anymore having the
opportunity to do this
[Music]
now we're gonna whisk you off to costa
rica and meet a woman who brings street
dogs into her sanctuary and there are so
many dogs you might find your best
friend here
one core trait in every dog is its ever
forgiving nature that's probably the
most valuable thing in a dog and it's
also its biggest pitfall because we have
dogs here who've been horribly hurt by
human beings and yet all they want to do
is find somebody else to love
[Music]
around the world strays mutts and street
dogs are victims of stigma
in costa rica leah battle is trying to
change that story she runs the
territorio de saguates it's a lush haven
for stray dogs to either be adopted or
to live out the rest of their days
territories
stands for land of the month
my name's leah battle better known as
crazy dog lady i guess i started
territorios aguatis partly because i've
always loved animals all animals
but it wasn't in my plans it wasn't like
i set out to do this the need for this i
think all over the world is because
there's a huge stigma around a dog that
doesn't have a breed they'll let mutts
wander on the streets or they'll
actually toss them on the streets
because they're not breed dogs the
solution isn't euthanizing a dog the
solution is make sure it's not born in
the first place
once it's here do something good for it
find a home or if not at least offer him
a place where he can be in peace and
happy
keeping territorial up and running is no
easy feat they eat 500 a day in food
alone leah has to work a full-time job
to keep all the dogs fed and healthy
territorio
stays about partly through
miracles i think
keeping this afloat is a huge task
it's a labor of love
you can't
pay someone to care for an animal truly
to remember their names to be gentle to
them while this place is a dog heaven
nothing beats getting adopted by a
loving family i'd say it's like kids at
kindergarten they love their friends at
school but oh they all want to go home
to mom and dad
[Music]
next we'll travel to india where a man
feeds 8 000 birds twice a day on his
rooftop
which i can't even believe because i
think these guys are hard enough to take
care of
[Applause]
[Music]
in chennai india there's a tiny camera
repair shop run by a man named joseph
seikar
and i had a sega under the police
worldwide
because every day he feeds thousands of
hungry parakeets on the roof of his home
[Music]
the 2006 tsunami that hit southeast asia
flooded parts of india and displaced
thousands of birds
cecar noticed a pair of parakeets
outside of his home and set some rice
out for them
then more started to show up
and well
foreign
feeding eight thousand parakeets twice a
day is a great expense cecar spends
about 40 percent of the money he makes
from repairing cameras buying food for
the birds
[Music]
but for the birdman of chennai there is
more to life than money
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
me
now we're going to hit the high seas and
meet a man sailing around the world and
he's got an unusual companion along with
him
uh
[Music]
at only 24 years old geraxude is aboard
a 30-foot boat sailing around the world
completely on his own
[Music]
from
[Music]
[Music]
he left his home in france two and a
half years ago
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
although he's been navigating alone he's
found an unlikely companion
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thanks for stopping by everyone we hope
you've enjoyed these four awesome animal
stories and speaking of animals click
the horse above us to subscribe and
don't forget to comment
see you later bye